[Music]
Disney's zombies is one of the biggest
Disney Channel movies of the year so far
with the impressive popularity of the
movie will we get a sequel wait until
you hear about some of the most
anticipated moments fans of the zombies
wanna see in part 2 don't forget to
subscribe to the things and give this
video a big thumbs up now let's check
out the 10 theories about Disney's
zombies to focus on the kids we've seen
the teens interact with each other but
what about the kids of the movie we're
introduced to Zoe who's Ed's little
sister she aspires to become a
cheerleader and looks up to see Brooks
cheer squad captain Bucky she was way
too awesome to be just forgotten about
with so many more questions what happens
to the kids well the second movie show
us where they go to school and some kind
of the challenges they face they could
take this story in so many different
directions by focusing on the little
ones or showing us what it's like to
actually raise zombies a youtuber Alice
bunny gives an excellent point by saying
we have no idea what happened to these
kids seabrooke high school is just for
high school students so where do kids on
these go for their education they're
definitely not just cooped up in their
town and waiting to grow up we'd love to
see the zombies also focus on elementary
school kids or even show those in the
kindergarten the interactions between
the zombie kids and the human kids would
be completely adorable
come on Disney we'd love to see more of
the kids in the sequel location
boundaries the youtuber Alice bunny also
explored another interesting theory in
the first movie the zombies are only
seen at school even though we know that
Seabrooke is most likely a huge town so
what would happen if the zombies went to
the beach or explored other places where
the cebra community might not yet be
used to them it would be interesting to
see the zombie parents doing regular
things like grocery shopping or running
errands while mixing with the humans
this concept can be taken in so many
different directions and we absolutely
can't wait to see what will happen come
on don't you want to see what a zombies
day-to-day life would look like in the
human world or whether or not they could
actually relax on a beach get a tan
or swim in the ocean we have a feeling
the second movie might actually explore
some of the location boundaries that
were set in the first one are the
zombies even allowed to do that now or
are they just limited to the area
outside of the school fans have so many
questions about this movie and we're
positive Disney won't ignore them
Riverdale okay hear us out on this one
if you're a fan of Riverdale you may
have heard the zombie rumors that
emerged back in March 2017 in Archie
comics which the show was based on we
see jugheads dog getting turned into a
zombie the dog then bites Jughead and
starts a zombie plague fans of the show
wondered if this could actually happen
on screen and the showrunner said that
it's definitely a possibility so what if
the second movie will be inspired by
Riverdale sure it might actually be much
darker than what we're used to but it
would be interesting think about
Riverdale as a musical with slightly
brighter colors than the show has now we
can definitely see that happening
perhaps the second movie will feature
some more dark and twisted turns and who
knows maybe the zombies and the humans
will be joined by new cast members that
will play the part which brings us to
our next point what do you think is it
too much of a coincidence that Riverdale
zombie rumor started at a time when the
first disney zombies were most likely
filmed we'd love to see some of the
Riverdale cast and zombies new cast we
absolutely love the original characters
from the zombies but we feel like Disney
will add new cast members for the second
movie similar to what they did to
descendants when we got introduced to
uma and Harry and they became one of our
favorite characters ever what we dilute
ly love is to see some easter-egg
characters from high school musical
after all it is the musical the zombies
movie gets compared most - but since
we're on the case of Riverdale we would
love to see a character like Veronica
Lodge on this show we have a feeling
she'd cause complete havoc and she'd
probably turned the entire town upside
down while zombies definitely isn't as
dark as Riverdale the show could
potentially turn a lot worse for the
sequel just imagine all the exciting
twists they could pull a love triangle a
new head cheerleader new villains there
are so many opportunities to give this
story a brand new twist we for sure have
a feeling there will be a new character
added to the mix and they'll change the
entire
well would be your ideal character for
the second zombies make sure you let us
know your own theories in the comments
for an exchange student but let's talk
about some of the theories and fan
fictions that already exist from the
moment the zombies movie appeared on
screen fans started getting their own
ideas and what they would like to see in
the movie Napoleon lovers 69 on Wattpad
introduces a brand-new character a
gorgeous foreign exchange student who
comes to Seabrook high and makes
everyone turn their heads including Zed
it's definitely a possibility isn't it
the student is of course human and she
has no idea that zombies are a thing but
naturally Zed changes her mind on how
she feels about them so how would
Addison reactives I started interacting
with a random foreign exchange student
who's just as confused about the whole
situation would there be fights or would
Zed find a new love and what would
Addison think about that seriously we're
totally down for this foreign exchange
student character imagine seeing their
own perspective of what's happening in
Seabrook we're curious to see how the
functionalities would change if an
outsider would experience what it's like
to live with zombies we totally approve
of this story and we definitely hope
Disney will take some inspiration from
these awesome Wattpad writers and don't
worry we have a lot more Wattpad
theories ahead of us lost sister this
Wattpad story belongs to Hannah hi at 14
and it is so adorable it happens before
the first movie and we can see the
sequel having some flashbacks to this in
this story the theory is that Zed and
Zoe have a long-lost sister called
Hannah
but she's adopted by Madison's parents
after they find her wandering around the
little girl also plays with her Z band
but Addison's parents of course have no
idea what that bracelet really means
after a few years hannah confides in
Addison that she really is a zombie and
for some reason the dad tells his kids
that they actually have another sister
just imagine if all this played out it
would definitely be an interesting
concept Hannah had a hard time adjusting
to the human world because the zombies
weren't yet accepted in the school and
were still considered freaks when it was
revealed that Hannah is
zombi Addison's parents didn't want her
anymore but that took her in and she
ended up with her original family but
then Addison decided to meet up with the
zombies and see what they're really like
what do you think is this a good enough
idea for the second movie or do you want
something else to have half zombie this
Wattpad story explores the possibility
of half zombies we've seen full zombies
and full humans that is it possible for
characters to be half zombies we feel
like this would be an interesting story
to explore in the new movie and Liam's
girl 99 from Wattpad decided to explore
it the theory is that Addison's dad had
an affair with the zombie who later got
pregnant it was decided that the girl
would live with her mother and her name
would be Zara
well at least that was the plan bazaars
mother passed away while giving birth to
her daughter
so Zara had to live with her father
Addison and Addison's mother as a half
zombie
Zara's dad acted funny around her
because he just didn't know what to do
as this wasn't in his plan and Zara had
no one to talk to about her zombie side
until she met Zoe who was a cheerleader
just like Addison but it also looks like
said how to think for Zara of course not
every part of this story could be taken
as actual theory but introducing hot
zombies would be interesting watch until
the end to find out what moment people
do want to see the most pretending fans
seem to love this theory of a possible
character that's pretending they're
human but they're actually a zombie and
it seems that just about everyone is
somehow connected to Addison we feel
like Addison's parents will definitely
be a huge part of the second movie at
least according to the fans would you
want to Addison to have another sister
this Wattpad story belongs to Alex Cooke
it's about a girl named Erica who was
adopted by Addison's parents she knows
that she's a zombie but she pretend to
be human so no one could suspect
anything
Erica also has the zband bracelet but
she keeps telling people it's a watch
she also wears a wig and always puts
makeup on to make sure people don't make
any assumptions about her skin all of
these sister stories really make us
wonder if Disney will actually listen
and put another kid in the second movie
it would tie with a lot of other
theories including the one about
focusing on the kids and adding new
characters besides there are
lot of talented kid actors out there
these days so we betta finding someone
to play the part wouldn't be a problem
our money is on Jojo sua she'd be a
perfect zombie child a new villain not
only do people want new zombie
characters they also want new villains
let's be honest
Disney zombies doesn't really have a
good enough villain like descendants but
with the way the story is actually
developing wouldn't you want to see what
a villain could do to the seabrooke town
the Wattpad user Emma Dianne M has an
interesting story about zombies being
attacked by a villain in this theory
someone wants all the zombies to be
destroyed these people hack the Z bands
and try to take over zombies and destroy
their lives
the writer notes that zombies might be
monsters but we all know that humans are
monsters too it would be interesting to
explore what a human mind is capable of
considering zombies have Z bands that
control them meanwhile we all know what
humans are capable of doing once they
have the power although this would mean
that the zombies would definitely be a
darker movie than were used to we're
down with it this show needs a good
villain and this theory actually makes
that possible just to imagine the
amazing songs we could get with a
villain character and the fact that this
villain would be human makes the entire
thing that much more interesting the
kiss out of all these theories and
fanfiction inspiration there's one thing
people want to see more than anything
else it's the kiss did you notice that
Zed and Addison never really kissed in
the first movie so what would happen if
they do would the consequence be similar
to a zombie bite we have a feeling
there's something more to this story and
Disney doesn't want to tell us until the
second movie we suspect
Addison would actually transform into a
zombie if she kissed Zed which would be
a complete plot twist to the entire
movie it's the one scene the fans want
to see the most we feel like Disney
might take advantage of that and bring a
brand new perspective or who knows maybe
the second movie we'll talk more about
Zed and Addison starting a family all we
know is we want to see more of these two
in the next movie but we sincerely
wonder what their story will look like
and of course most importantly if
they'll ever share an on
Green smooch because let's be honest so
what the fans want to see the most and
that's all for our video what do you
think will we get a zombies to movie let
us know in the comments thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]